huh
yeah
and to kill a full stage that is correct
from God yeah yeah that's seven yeah no
no I'm not saying no I'm not saying it's
wrong with it yeah yeah but I wanna in
Judaism you believe spawning the
adultery
is the only man or woman
it was only a woman that should respond
to death if you commit adultery
yes
what's your name
but are you not amazed that many Jewish
people in London or Britain or Europe
they believe in the scripture they
believed in apostate
but you have no there's no one in social
media original anger Judaism
[Laughter]
but the point here is in social media in
the news in newspaper I've never seen a
campaign and gets Jedi judaic belief
even though you believe to stoned
adultera to kill a prostate why why are
you going to ask them I don't know think
about it because like
people
you know and what's happening now just
imagine at the time of Hitler
you see some people attacking Jewish
people because of their beliefs what are
you doing man
now the Muslim people oppressed on the
world yeah but yet some people attacking
Islam so and the question to ask these
people imagine you live at a time where
Hitler with a friend or oppressing
Jewish people
Jewish belief
I want to do it you know so but think
about it
what's your name Isaac
I love you yes yes
Muslims
I said it wasn't me say no no you've
done it then
for the Islam haters in America in
Europe you're like cowards
you're a coward I'll tell you and Jewish
people I have not seen Bob the donkey
and the other donkeys Christians
Donkey by the way but the Christian
missionaries here Jewish people
management speakers
and never see a Christian or Islam hater
coming to a Jewish person asking him
what do you believe in Kingdom state
but they do to the Muslims yeah even
though the Jewish people will live in it
but they just say no no but they're not
implement it will not implemented in
Britain but I believe it's right
so why did you confront you people
because you know the answer
before because you kiss that sauce you
know that's the reality so my brothers
and sisters out there if Islam hates I
come to you tell you listen you believe
it say I'm gone do you have a problem
with it do you remember Danny below the
the handwrites of uh whose name uh Tommy
Robinson since I debate with him he
never came back
because they work for the zionists
understand they work for the zionists
and they know if they're speaking
against judaic believe Jewish people
they were their funds because of
in the stand they'll be cut off so
that's what you do if you say I'm gone
why I don't see you like this false
prophets Force donkey I mean it's not
force okay it's a true donkey you know
or what's his name uh David wood this
donkey there's many donkeys but I have
no respect for them there's some
Christians my neighbors people that I
know are respected mushroom respect but
these people why because they are liars
you know hyena hyena here so you
hello
they come here
when they Jewish people believe in the
same thing
so he said openly guess you never see on
social media this video will be taken
out and it's them haters say be aware of
July believe
but if I said it's what they think they
would take my clip out said look what
they believe
we are the highest
you're an idiot that's right of course
straight away I mean they told me
Robinson he seems like he tried he's
trying to come back and get in a
different way with a different face like
I agree with Muslims and so on you know
because he became recently became
irrelevant so he wants to come back
yeah and I've heard him speaking about
Islamic legislation and we made a video
about him long time ago
from Saudi foreign
if it's a man-made religion he will tell
us of man laughter for his desires
understand why there is the only the
only word that has been waged and guess
is Islam Islam because Islam is against
the evil ones
Islam came to protect us to protect our
wealth protect our health protect our
society our families and evil ones that
will destroy all of that
how can I protect this by going back to
God to Allah the true God
you know
and I hope this reached Tommy Robinson
comes next to us stop lying against
Islam Islam and stop speaking to
ignorance Muslims come and speak with me
shall I become Muslim
oh you stopped coming to you stop
showing your face like your friend Danny